[Music]
a moment of celebration for a group of
cocoa farmers from bolivia's ethnic
younger community
[Music]
they'd spent 10 days trying to take
control of this marketplace in the
capital la paz from a rival group of
farmers
the scene is in contrast to the violent
confrontation earlier with security
forces outside
there protesters blocked a nearby road
and its surrounding area and cascades of
tear gas dispersed the crowds
but they soon reformed breaking through
police lines to enter the marketplace
thank god god did justice for us so we
could regain our coca market
we're only the producers the police who
support another group of coca growers
wants to silence us with gas and bullets
le paz has been a battleground between
two rival groups of coca farmers one
loyal to the government the other to the
opposition which had taken the market
from its younger rivals last month the
marketplace is important because more
than 90 of bolivia's coca leaf business
is done here and it generates 173
million us dollars a year
the coca leaf is often chewed and brewed
by people in the andes to cope with
altitude sickness
and it's also a raw ingredient in
cocaine
members of the younger community say
they are the rightful and historic
owners of the coca industry
they've called on the government to
allow them to continue this tradition
and they accuse their leaders of trying
to profit from their trade
they say tough working conditions have
forced them to protests
we demand that the government under the
general coca law that a resolution has
to be passed to enable the transfer of a
commercialization market to a new site
for coca growers in order to guarantee
the peace and unity of the youngest
president eva morales has accused the
youngest of being paid off to act
against his government
he says he's organizing a counter-march
next week
and the battle for control of bolivia's
lucrative coca trade hangs in the
balance
laura about and manly al jazeera